My friend, this is Manuel Tamayo speaking to you
[Music] I
'll put it on speaker so everyone can't be heard
eh I'm about to publish a new
book today to come and present it to Buenos
Aires as there is Progress
no don't believe me
the obelisk is the symbol of Buenos
Aires
[Music  ]
[Music]
Tell me one thing you put in the
mixture milk and cinnamon syrup oil
oil look it's no more
rotten mushroom a mess give me money
please yes how much I'll give
who taught you how to wash the windows
dear no no no no  no no no no no no no no no no
no my version is without garlic let's
see how this is
up here you don't eat anymore neither here nor in
any restaurant that belongs to me you don't
have with my guest I'm talking to
you you are discriminating because of their
skin color let's say no to discrimination
[Music]
[Applause]
I have to find out through the networks that
you are in the middle of a mental breakdown.
Do you think I'm telling you the truth?
And how would you define yourself as a teacher, as
a food critic, as a writer,
as a journalist?  He would say that I am nothing
[Music]
He says that he thinks it is horrible